fifteen months after the murder of Saudi
journalist Shamal kesaji in the kingdoms
consulate in Istanbul the fallout
continues Jeff Bezos the boss of the
world's largest online shop Amazon also
owns the Washington Post the newspaper
kesaji wrote for he's now at the center
of a hacking probe UN Human Rights
experts including Agnes calamar who
investigated Kershaw G's murder say
they've looked at forensic analysis that
points to data being stolen from bezos's
phone in 2018 that happened after Bezos
received whatsapp messages from the
personal account of the Saudi Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman possibly the
experts say to try and influence
articles in The Washington Post the
initial expert who conducted the
forensic investigation concluded with
medium to high certainty that the source
of the hacking was a video file sent to
mr. Bezos
- except from an account owned by the
Crown Prince
on the sidelines of the World Economic
Forum the Saudi Energy Minister
responded to the allegations why is it a
mockery so people are concerned at the
same time The Wall Street Journal
reported that Saudi officials close to
the crown prince said they were aware of
a plan to hack bezos's phone as part of
a broader intimidation campaign against
hisagi but not aware of any attempt to
blackmail him well I think absurd is
exactly the right word the idea that the
conference would hack Jeff Bezos his
phone is absolutely silly as Bezos
supported cushaw G's fiance following
his murder in 2018 relations with bin
Salman soured bezos's security team
alleged last March that the Kingdom
gained private information from his
phone involving text messages between
him and a former TV news presenter
this latest analysis implicates the
crown
prince for the first time I think that
it's hard to believe that if they had
this successful capability and were
brazenly willing to use it
against one of the most powerful people
in the world that they would stop there
the Saudis have been accused of other
hacking attacks but Bezos is by far the
most high-profile person involved and
these latest allegations are expected to
only worsen relations between the
world's richest man and the kingdom a
strategic ally of the u.s. Nicola gage
al Jazeera earlier Jeff Bezos tweeted a
photo of himself which Marcos Keys
fiance unveiling a plaque last October
marking the one-year anniversary of his
murder at the hashtag Jamaal Glen Karl
is a former deputy national intelligence
officer for transitional threats at the
CIA
he says the Amazon phone hack does not
surprise him and intelligence officer it
sounds like business as usual I'm not
surprised at all that that happened I am
a bit surprised that MBS himself would
allow or the intelligence service would
use the head of State's own phone so
easily traceable but that they did so
doesn't surprise me it's pretty clear
it's not that Bezos is rich that makes
him of interests what makes him of
interest is that he owns the Washington
Post one of the three most influential
media newspapers in the United States
and therefore with global implications
which in seeking truth and I I want to
emphasize that the Washington Post seeks
facts it does not engage in a campaign
hostile to MBS or Saudi Arabia it
publishes facts and the facts have been
damning and harmful to Saudi image and
operations and because of that it is
then of some well of interest to Saudi
Arabia to have information that could
discredit or The Washington Post or its
owner or the information by creating a
counter story which is not the truth
which is a diversion but that's the
motivation certainly this has not been
the most sophisticated operation I
gather I'm
a cyber expert but I know operations and
you do want to try to have an operation
conducted so that it cannot be
associated directly with your chief of
state that seems to be a rather obvious
thing to try to avoid and then I gather
that the the hacking tool used was not
the most sophisticated or at least
easily hidden so that seems to be
ham-fisted but I have to say not
surprising again because this seems not
to have been the most subtle service or
operation